et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec maturi ce professeur des écoles et
secrétaire snudi fo de moselle
bonjour naturiste merci d'être en direct
avec nous par téléphone sur rtl france
comment est-ce que vous jugez ces
nouvelles ce nouveau protocole sanitaire
qu'on a appris hier dans la presse
notamment fait part dès qu'on
s'entendait à une situation
catastrophique qui ait ce qui était
confirmée par les premiers retours qu'on
a vu qu'on a eu ce matin parce qu'une
fois de plus l'êta n'a été fait alors
qu'une foule a chanté parlé de
raz-de-marée des quelques jours et que
le conseil scientifique avait filmé une
dizaine de jours qu'un quart des
enseignants très positif en garde
d'enfants ou positif avant la fin du
mois de janvier donc le protocole c'est
la énième version du protocole je crois
qu'on en est à la 48ème c'est votre ont
pas envie d'y aller
il est mis à jour deux fois en quelques
jours le 31 décembre puis hier soir à 18
heures pour une reprise ce matin 8
heures est-ce que c'est impeccable
évidemment le délai est très court est
ce que c'est a piqué mais est-ce que
c'est souhaitable de nouvelles mesures
pour revenir un petit peu sur les
modifications de cette fois ci sur le
protocole
trois choses que trois exemples que je
suis très il ya le fait qu'on ferme une
classe même au delà de trois cas
positifs et on renvoie la diffusion
haute autorité locale et protocole
précis maintenant que le on est ferme
une classe que qu'en cas par exemple par
exemple d'un très grand nombre de
classes de cycle 3 qui est très flou
ensuite les cas contactez les élèves
voulaient précisé pas de revenir à
l'école s'il fournit sa tête antigénique
ou pcr immédiat puis un autotest à j + 2
j + 4
ils seront distribués aux enfants et les
parents devront faire des attestations
sur l'honneur que les tests sont
négatifs donc on s'est reposé la
fontaine tout de tout des autres élèves
et des personnels sur l'honnêteté des
parents alors que partout il faut
montrer patte blanche avec le tpiy serge
seynaeve extrême maxine au complet
qui doit gagner contre ce protocole on
trouve les moments de convivialité on
interdit aux enseignants de prendre le
café debout en salle dès notre retour on
peut quand même se poser la question
s'ils avaient pas mieux à faire que de
proposer des mesures telles que société
les professeurs est ce que est ce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'absentéisme à cause de ce
nouveau variant alors on a déjà moi dans
mon département j'ai eu plusieurs
retours
de collègues ce matin qu'ils sont qui
sont positifs et malheureusement pas
remplacer sa séance avait créé avec un
problème c'est d'un point depuis depuis
des mois déjà ça n'a malheureusement pas
s'arranger on est premiers jours de
classe et déjà des classes qui n'ont pas
d'enseignants
moi je tiens quand même à dire basta ce
que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que ont
effectivement on se poser la question de
reporter la rentrée ça a été évoqué dans
les médias pendant un moment ses
vacances je pense que la question n'est
pas là c'est un faux débat et c'est
important de le repréciser parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde tient
à ce que l'école puisse rester ouverte
c'est la volonté du gouvernement pour
des raisons essentiellement économiques
on a rien compris mais c'est faisable
seulement si on y met les moyens et les
moyens nous ça fait bientôt deux ans
quand les réclames et deux ans qu'on ne
nous entend pas du tout quelles sont ses
boys fait que vous réclamez écoutez moi
je vous donnerai tout ça le premier
exemple le qui pour moi est emblématique
d'une maîtrise de notre ministère c'est
les masques
sans doute entendu que le ministre a
encore dit hier je crois qu'on a besoin
de cette bd aux enseignants parce qu'on
ne peut pas sa place correctement avec
un masque ffp2 c'est toujours qu'elle
réclame depuis le départ pour les
personnes qui en font la demande
aujourd'hui d'éducation hassan ii
fournit aux personnels qui masque en
tissu alors que partout ailleurs le haut
rendement la masca minimum chirurgicale
les enseignants non vous en dit houle ou
encore que des masques en tissu oui on
sait ça
c'est
évidemment donc 2-0 on est vraiment là
on y est nous en première ligne
l'optimiste dit que les masques ffp2
sont réservés aux soignants on pense
qu'on est en première ligne mais aussi
on est bien bien contente les soignants
puissent en bénéficier il ya un moment
c'est plus possible de continuer comme
ça or le master exemple il ya plein
d'autres exemples les capteurs de co2
les touristes 14 heures le dépistage
systématique et régulier des choses
qu'on demande depuis des mois et sur
lesquels il s'est toujours bien passé et
tout comme venant de 6 dès la création
de postes statutaires
d'enseignants d'un lâchage la charnière
de l'état de colère est pour l'instant
très très près aucune réponse de
naturistes très court pardon je vous
pose une dernière question le monsieur
médecin du gouvernement incite les
mineurs à se faire leur dose de à se
faire faire leur dose de rappel est ce
que la vaccination pourraient être des
enfants évidemment pourrait être une
solution selon vous
son sofa on n'a pas de position je pense
que chacun libre de
décider pour soi même à voir qu'ils ont
fait de ces deux faits de mettre en
place les moyens pour que pour qu'on
puisse travailler dans des conditions
correctes en sort prendre de risques
aujourd'hui les enseignants mais aussi
des parents s'inquiètent en jeu takam a
précisé que les départs ont aussi qu'il
honnit n'ont pas d'eau ni leurs enfants
à l'école ce matin on a lu plusieurs
retours parce qu'ils ont peur pour leur
famille pour l'entourage avec parfois
des gens malades dans l'entourage
séparent seulement de la caf n'est pas
seulement du côté des enseignants
effectivement il ya des parents positif
qui est du coup n'ont pas mis leur
enfant à l'école aussi se met ça va sans
doute mais il ya aussi des parents qui
ont des personnes vulnérables de leur
entourage qu'ils ont peur de remettre
leurs enfants à l'école parce que je
rappelle qu'en maternelle l'enfant ne
porte pas de masque
et donc les enfants sont son entretien
fait pas de brassage mais tout le monde
revient de congés d'été où on a côtoyé
et pas mal de monde et il voit là c'est
très compliqué cissac encore une fois
parler du problème du remplacement parce
que ce qu'on est vraiment dans une
situation qui devient ingérable et on
manque d'enseignants partout et le
ministère refuse de recruter de recruter
des enseignants des par des contractuels
mais la réalité dans le double en
carrière qu'on recrute massivement pour
améliorer remplacement sauf pour une
troupe a candidement donc c'est la
poudre aux yeux encore une fois c'est de
la merde et de labels comme de la part
du ministère mais mais derrière la
réalité c'est qu'on trouve plus de
candidats et c'est pas ne sera pas
s'arranger du jour au lendemain donc il
ya vraiment des mesures à prendre et ça
fait des mois qu'on le demande on attend
du gouvernement maintenant on arrête de
faire de la com et qu'on passe à des
mesures concrètes merci morice merci on
a entendu notre message on n'a plus le
temps malheureusement merci en tout cas
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions sur rt france